Kind of cool that we get to make a movie.
Kind of really, really crazy that we get to make a movie.
I kind of have to pinch myself everyday.
Do you need one now?
Yeah, can you? Would you?
Real?
Is it? I don't know.
I'm Grace Kaufman, and I play Lennie Walker.
Hey, my name is Jacques Colimon. I play Joe Fontaine.
Can I ask you a question?
Please, please do.
What did you do when you found out you got the role?
I just felt the most honored that I was chosen to play a role
that meant so much to me, and then I started crying.
Like ugly crying? Or like...
Like ugly crying. Like the ugliest that it gets.
You like Lennie?
I like her a lot.
I really love her passion for things.
You think you'd be friends with her in real life?
I think so.
As somebody who has had their fair share of grief and coming to terms with loss
we would get along because there's a mutual understanding there.
That's really beautiful.
Oh thanks.
I've said too much.
Lennie has trepidation with playing clarinet, right?
Yeah, especially after she loses Bailey.
She finds it really hard to pursue the things that she's passionate about.
It's really challenging for her to find that momentum
to play the clarinet how she used to.
Clarinet is a hard instrument.
Lennie blows my mind how she's able to play
something that's so challenging so flawlessly.
But you do it too.
Yeah, but I had to learn clarinet for this role.
I thought you told me that you were playing clarinet for like ten years.
Oh, uh...
Is that what I said?
Look at this.
Come on, this way.
Are you excited to get out in these woods?
I mean who wouldn't?
These trees are like over a thousand years old.
We're so lucky we just get to frolic in this.
That's like basically what we get to do.
It's like the trees are talking.
What are they saying to you?
Look at me. The all beautiful in the way that is shiny and green.
What's your favorite moment on set?
Individually with each person I've had such heartfelt and hilarious moments.
It's been really special.